The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: What we've
managed through badgering
the utilities relentlessly is
to get them to agree to measure
part or all of the
high-volume gas leaks
that they're going to
fix this next year.
But we need a method to do that.
So one part of
today is hackathon.
And you can choose which
group you want to go with.
The part that I'm
going to be working on
is coming up with that method to
quickly, easily, using utility
common tools, measure
the emissions off
of high-volume gas leaks.
And if we can do this--
if it's possible--
the state will enact
the regulations
that this must be done
with every high-volume gas
leak from now on.
So this is an incredible chance
to create a state-wide program
to allow for feedback
and transparency
in the system to allow them
to do their job much better
in terms of reducing emissions
from natural gas leaks.
Does that somewhat make sense?
And we've got some of the cool
tools that the utilities use,
and lots of information
about how to do that.
PROFESSOR: So who knows
what a gas leak smells like?
That's the most kind of direct
sensor we have-- our noses.
Who doesn't really
have a good idea
of what a gas leak smells like?
OK, great.
Well, I have these
scratch and sniff cards,
so you can find out.
[LAUGHTER]
And so you open these things up.
Does anyone want to
remind themselves
of what a gas leak smells like?
Well, this can be a little
reminder [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, so, take one,
and pass them around.
You just open it up.
And there's a little
teardrop shaped blue thing.
And you just scratch
that, and you smell it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you smell that?
OK, so when I got into
this, I didn't even
know what a gas
leak smelled like.
Like, six years
ago, I had no idea.
And then once I smelled it,
it's like riding a bike.
Now, if you haven't smelled it--
you're going to have that--
AUDIENCE: What's the
chemical in the smell?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's a family
of compounds called mercaptans.
They're all
sulfur-based compounds.
And our noses are just very,
very sensitive to them.
They're injected into
the gas because methane
itself is odorless.
And it was actually
mandated by federal law
to be put in there after
a huge explosion happened
in New London, Texas, that
killed hundreds of kids
in that school.
And no one smelled it.
So this odorant is added at
the parts per billion range.
It's like maybe five
to 10 parts per billion
of this odorant, mercaptan.
So we use a number of techniques
to measure these gas leaks.
As a citizen and as
community science,
your nose is really a
very powerful sensor.
The industry, what they do
is they use some sniffers.
They've been around for decades.
One of the things they do
is use this thing called
a combustible gas indicator.
And I'll just turn it on.
You can hear the noise.
That's a pump.
And so it's pulling in air
through this little hole here.
Often there's an
extension on this
so that it can go deeper down--
like a meter down
into the ground.
So good thing-- right
now, we're measuring 0--
0% gas.
OK?
This thing's pulling in about
a half a liter per minute.
That's the pump.
So you see the 0 there.
And when we go out on our
drive-around on the 31st--
those of you who can make it--
if we come upon a gas leak in
our very high precision, very
sensitive sniffer--
this one's a little
bit more coarse.
But we can get out, and
poke around, and find out,
and pinpoint where is
it under the surface
that that gas is coming out.
OK?
So maybe I'll just--
oh, I don't know.
I guess I'll turn this off.
AUDIENCE: Might have to do a
controlled experiment where you
can match people against that.
So send people and one of them.
You know?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You know, that's a good idea.
But I will tell you, the
lower limit on this thing
is about 500 parts
per million methane.
That's the lower detection limit
on this, which is very high.
Does anyone know what
the background methane
value is in our atmosphere in
units of parts per million?
Any wild guesses?
AUDIENCE: Two per billion.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, per million--
a little over two
parts per million.
40,000 parts per million
is when it gets explosive--
40,000 parts per million.
OK?
AUDIENCE: That's 80
times [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So there's different ranges
at which this problem
has different impacts.
Our global value of
two parts per million
now is about something
like 50% greater
than it was in the
pre-industrial condition.
And so the greenhouse
gas impacts
of even two parts per
million is very big.
The instrumentation
in our band--
GPS-enabled sniffer
detected a series of leaks
along about a 1/8 of a mile
portion of that street.
So we've got this graph--
and I will show you later--
with these peaks that come out.
They could be plotted right
out on Google Earth, OK?
It's probable that
those leaks are not
coming from the new pipe--
the new West Roxbury Lateral.
But they're probably coming from
the adjacent pipes that are old
and leaking that have
already been there.
The real lost opportunity
there, in addition
to the fact that we don't
need the new pipeline,
is that they paved brand-new
paving and brand-new sidewalks.
They didn't fix the old
leaking pipelines when they
put in this brand-new pipeline.
And Eversource, whose
territory that is, by the way,
is a coinvestor in the West
Roxbury Lateral Pipeline.
So apparently, they just
didn't care about maintaining
their own infrastructure.
AUDIENCE: Why
wasn't it mandated?
Why wouldn't the state--
AUDIENCE: Working on it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So anyway, that's what happened.
And so we took a
picture of this.
We have the data set.
And what you'll see
is peaks and valleys.
There may be like
15 or 20 of them.
But are there are
15 or 20 leaks.
We don't know.
And if you want to go
over to the section
that we're working at, you
will be able to think about,
is like, what is a leak?
How many leaks are there when
you get this series of spikes?
If the spikes go like that-- tip
down, and come back up again,
and go down, is that
one leak or two leaks?
And the fact of the
matter is we don't yet
have a very universal
definition of what a leak is.
So you will help
do a leak count.
And you'll help
determine, hopefully,
what an objective
leak analysis can
be by looking at these Google
Earth images of gas leaks.
PROFESSOR: And they're
gorgeous images.
And it's just super fun.
You feel like you're the only
one who knows this information.
It's great.
AUDIENCE: Do you know the
material of recent leak
types and [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
the leak-prone pipe--
most of it is cast iron.
And it goes back-- some
pipes are over 100 years old.
I think Audrey might
have mentioned.
There's also wrought iron.
There's not much of that.
But that's a very old
leak-prone pipe as well.
Bare steel is another
leak-prone pipe.
They're all being replaced--
well, when they're replaced,
they're replaced
with plastic pipe.
And that is not as leaky
because it's newer.
AUDIENCE: This may be the
wrong question, wrong time.
Three or four years ago,
there was a big issue here
with Google Maps.
And then Google outfitted
every single car,
and tracked and published their
gas leaks all over the place.
And rather
humorously, Wellesley,
was one of the biggest centers
of the universe of gas leaks
that they found.
As they did all the Google
drive-bys, they [INAUDIBLE]..
They didn't know where that
fit into this town [INAUDIBLE]
technology they were using.
But they published this,
and all this, but that--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So we published our
Boston data in 2013.
And that was all of
the gas [INAUDIBLE]----
over 3,000 leaks in Boston.
Very soon after that,
Google partnered
with the Environmental
Defense Fund
to basically take
this nationwide.
And so part of doing
that was coming back
to the greater Boston area.
And they did their own map.
They got one leak
per mile in Boston.
We got four leaks
So that's part of
figuring this out.
So almost everything that's
under the streets and sidewalks
in Boston, Somerville,
Cambridge, Newton, Brookline,
is just about a half a
pound per square inch
of pressure under the
streets and sidewalks.
But it's like a tree.
You have these trunk lines.
And you have the big branches.
And then you have
the little twigs.
So you have these intermediate
branches running down
Route 9 that--
it's either 22 or it's 40 psi.
And it's leaking.
PROFESSOR: So
today, you'll either
decide to work on visualizing
the data, looking at the data,
or working on figuring out how
to measure the high-volume gas
leaks.
So you'll sort of self-select
into whatever group
you want to do.
Is there a question back here?
AUDIENCE: Just a basic question.
Do you know how deep
these lines were buried?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's variable.
About three feet is
generally how deep they are.
They put them deep
enough that it
will reduce the frequency
with which they freeze.
But in frost conditions--
deep freezes--
you can get mechanical
disturbance due to frost.
And you can have broken
mains, and things like that.
But anything's possible.
You know, one thing
I've learned is
that I mean, for the
most part, gas lines run
along the same axis as a street.
But they'll run diagonal.
And they'll be on both
sides of the street.
And they'll run under sidewalks.
And they'll go
this way and that.
And I can just see
any configuration.
There's a legacy effect of this.
It can be like
spaghetti down there.
AUDIENCE: Are there maps
of the existing pipeline?
PROFESSOR: Yes, and no.
There are public
documents that show
the operating pressure for that
natural grid's service area.
And I can share that graph.
But there's not the
detailed information
on those maps that tell
you the diameter, the age,
and the material of
all of the pipes.
There are selected
parts that we know of.
I mean, some of these have,
obviously, these maps.
But they're not public.
Only some have been made public.
And it's very selective.
PROFESSOR: So you can look
at how to visualize the data,
and get to figure out how many
leaks there are in Chelsea--
how exciting-- and
actually see where
the leaks are, or figure out
how to measure the emissions.